[Musica]
il titolo di questo text passato e
futuro Ma quando parliamo di future in
realtà di Che futuro parliamo del futuro
del
dell'energia il futuro delle aziende il
futuro della società o anche della
Salute Cioè è molto vagono come come
definizione Forse però dovremmo guardare
un attimo in passato perché allora se
andiamo a vedere il passato Capiamo che
cosa che quando c'è un'innovazione
piccola o anche un qualcosa che ci porta
in avanti viene modificato tutto quello
che in realtà conosciamo è bastato ad
esempio nella nel Paleolitico la la
scoperta e l'utilizzo di piccoli arnesi
tipo questi qua per portare L'uomo da
una società di tipo
Paleolitico al Neolitico appunto il
Neolitico che ha portato con questi
attrezzi ad
un passaggio da una vita da raccoglitore
Cacciatore ha un uomo agricoltore
l'agricoltore quindi l'ha portato ad
essere non più
girovago ma stanziale essere stanziale
portava molti prodotti alla terra e
questo ha fatto sì che l'uomo poteva
unirsi in comunità questo è la parte
primordiale di quello che è poi diventa
una globalizzazione Se volete Però se
torniamo ai giorni Un po' più recenti
senza andare al Paleolitico nel 1800 è
stato L'invenzione del Vapore che è
stato sfruttato specialmente per quanto
riguarda L'industria del del ferrovie
navali E con questo si avvicinarono i
continenti aumentarono le operazioni
commerciali
e quindi la gente incominciò a
scambiarsi le materie prime nel 1900 è
stata poi l'elettricità invece che portò
un'innovazione enorme forse la più
grossa se ci pensiamo Grazie
all'elettricità e grazie ai Principi di
un ingegnere americano Taylor e grazie a
Ford che credette in questi nuovi
principi venne creata la catena di
montaggio la catena di montaggio faceva
sì che i prezzi si abbassassero e Ford
motorizzò mezza America con il suo
modello T proprio in onore a Taylor
veniamo ai nostri giorni più o meno nel
1960 fanno compaiono sulle nostre linee
produttive il robot i robot insieme ai
primi PC i primi computer il robot è una
parola che deriva dal cieco vuol dire
cioè con robot che vuol dire lavori
forzati ed erano le prime macchine che
andavano ad alleggerire quello che è il
lavoro umano adesso siamo Nell'era della
digitalizzazione quindi
la società 4.0 che utilizza
l'informatica per muovere i robot e
viene anche definita l'era della
produzione ciclica questa
l'era 4.0 naturalmente oltre che
nell'industria ha portato anche a un
modo di vivere diverso Pensate cosa è
successo con il web con internet e
praticamente l'era dell'informazione
disponibile per tutti Pensate solo cosa
è successo negli anni negli ultimi due
anni di pandemia no il fatto di avere
determinati strumenti ci ha fatto fare
dei passi avanti di 10 anni ad esempio
con con il lavoro a distanza No non
eravamo ancora pronti per un lavoro di
distanza siamo stati obbligati e e
abbiamo cavalcato Tant'è vero che adesso
facciamo io faccio le riunioni a
distanza una volta era impensabile su
YouTube tutti fanno riunioni lezione a
distanza anche lezioni di fitness Allora
mi ritengo io in una posizione fortunata
Io faccio il medico del lavoro vado
all'interno delle aziende posso vedere
da vicino come
l'innovazione impatta sulla salute
dell'uomo perché tutte queste novità
queste innovazioni che abbiamo visto nel
nel passato sono andata a impattare
sulla nostra salute
il primo a occuparsi in realtà della
Salute legata all'attività lavoratore
lavorativa su questo signore qua
Bernardino Ramazzini che nacque a fine
Settecento e morì nel 19714 1714 che
scrisse il demordere artificio in
diatriba prese in considerazione 54
mansioni dell'epoca naturalmente e le
correlò al tipo di patologie che queste
mansioni potevano far scaturire sulle
persone e uscì a guardarlo adesso ci
sono delle cose molto interessanti di
un'attualità eh eccezionale perché ad
esempio guardate in uno dei questi
capitolo ad esempio lavoratori sedentari
e loro malattie dovrebbero essere
consigliato loro di fare esercizio
fisico in una certa misura contrastare i
danni causati da molti giorni di vita
sedentaria già Allora 1700 Si parlava di
vita sedentaria che insomma era tutto da
vedere la tipologia di lavoro
non solo supplemento capitolo malattie
di screening e notai qua e lo stress
lavoro correlato si supponeva queste
persone avevano un grande impegno e
motivo di concentrazione e anche per
loro aveva dei consigli Non solo anche i
primordiali la primordiale
la primordiale Praticamente il lavori in
piedi quindi
il primordiali principi di ergonomia no
sulla postura veniva già qui nel 1700
Bernardino Ramazzini quindi è stato il
padre della medicina del lavoro ma è
stato anche in certi sensi il padre
dell'epigenetica l'epigenetica che è
quella scienza che studia tutti quei
fattori che vanno a influire sul nostro
DNA non modificandolo ma fanno in modo
che i geni del nostro DNA diano
un'espressione genetica e può modificare
anche il nostro fenotipo quali sono
Quali sono i fattori epigenetici più
importanti sono l'alimentazione
l'attività fisica l'ambiente in cui
viviamo e anche le nostre emozioni tutte
queste caratteristiche possono
modificare il nostro DNA almeno per
quanto riguarda l'espressione
L'uomo però ha sempre avuto un certo
rispetto e paura delle proprie
invenzioni Tant'è vero che c'è una
sindrome che si chiama la sindrome di
Frankenstein che è stata proprio creata
da quella che è il romanzo di Mary
Shelley Dove appunto uno scienziato
mettendo in pratica quello che è la
tecnologia Allora parliamo nel 1700
poteva mettere in atto aveva creato un
mostro da pezzi anatomici e grazie
all'elettricità l'aveva dato vita questo
mostro sapete la storia da prima buono
poi in contatto con l'umanità è
diventato cattiva la paura dell'uomo di
creare cose e perdere il controllo e in
realtà le invenzioni vanno sempre
valutate a lungo termine questi due
signori qua sono i fratelli Lumière nel
1895 andarono a Parigi firmarono dei
Passeggeri che scendevano dal treno
proiettarono questo prossimi video
questo filmato a degli a quelli che
erano gli scienziati accademici
dell'oric definirono
quell'invenzione totalmente inutile noi
adesso viviamo nella società
dell'immagine molto questi qua
potrebbero essere i nonni di Chiara
Ferragni o comunque dei nostri
influenzare le società all'immagine
nasceva il Cinematografo Ma se andiamo
anche a vedere quello che è successo
nella medicina
felini Hoffman nel 1897
sintetizzò l'aspirina che penso che sia
uno dei farmaci più utilizzati al mondo
sei mesi dopo vi era una necessità di
aiutare dei problemi Le persone che
avevano un problema respiratorio e i
bambini che leggermente esagitati e
quindi le mamme volevano un prodotto che
li facesse dormire venne creato questo
sciroppo vedete
eroi che funzionava molto bene perché
l'hanno preso i bambini poi l'hanno
preso le mamme hanno preso i nonni
e nel 1900 si calcola che la sola città
di New York aveva utilizzava due
tonnellate di eroina
Quindi erano praticamente
una una città praticamente di
eroinomani come sempre accade quando
però le invenzioni scappano di mano
l'uomo deve intervenire ponendo delle
leggi qui poi ci sarà la storia
dell'eroina e del
narcotraffico E questa è un'altra storia
ancora sempre per quanto riguarda il
campo farmacologico Nel 1986 il denafil
c'era bisogno di un farmaco che aiutasse
le persone con un problema ad angina
pectorius patologie del cuore ad
arrivare più sangue
venne creato nel fanale venne dato delle
persone in reparto dell'ospedale tranne
che un infermiere si è accorto che ogni
mattina che si faceva il giro
l'infermiera all'interno dell'ospedale i
pazienti maschi si girano a pancia in
giù
il farmaco funzionava molto bene È nato
il Viagra non funzionava dove doveva
funzionare quindi il cuore si può
abbandonato e
questo è un altro dei farmaci che ha
cambiato un po' anche i nostri usi e
costumi
Questo è il museo del futuro
Perché l'uomo come ho detto ha sempre
avuto bisogno di cercare di avere un
controllo sulle proprie invenzioni
abbiamo visto i casi precedenti questo
museo qui lo trovo molto emblematico
è stato creato è stato diciamo
inaugurato quest'anno il 2 febbraio a
Dubai e lo trovo emblematico in quanto
come vedete a tutte quelle che sono le
caratteristiche che dovremo tenere in
considerazione quando pensiamo al futuro
si appoggia sull'erba che a Dubai non è
cosa da poco e quindi rappresenta le
nostre radici col passato a livello
della metropolitana che è il presente
e alto e alto 75 metri 77 metri
praticamente un edificio di 25 piani non
poca roba la cosa interessante è questo
vuoto qua interno questa forma toroidale
che gli architetti li hanno studiato
questo architetto Killa design che tra
l'altro è uno dei palazzi più più
considerato uno dei palazzi più belli al
mondo ed è stato costruito tra la
collaborazione tra l'uomo e
l'intelligenza artificiale che ha
calcolato al millimetro ogni pezzo di
acciaio perché doveva servire per la
costruzione per farla stare in piedi
quella parte lì quella parte che secondo
gli autori ehm gli architetti deve
essere riempita dalle innovazioni la
cosa interessante di questo museo e per
quello ve lo sottoposto e che è un museo
dinamico e parla di invenzioni che non
vedremo tra un secolo tra 150 anni ma da
invenzioni che vanno a impattare da qua
ai prossimi 15 anni
E cos'è che quindi si nota all'interno
di questo museo e che ritengo sia
importantissimo do cosa dovrei Quali
sono le caratteristiche che
un'invenzione dovrebbe tenere in
considerazione dal momento che viene
messa sul mercato
due cose principali dovrebbe avere un
impatto positivo sull'ambiente e un
impatto positivo sulla salute le uniche
due cose che realmente contano Per
quanto riguarda l'ambiente
bisognerebbe tenere in considerazione
quella che è l'impronta ecologica
l'imprente ecologica è praticamente un
indice abbastanza complicato da da
calcolare però in linea di massima e il
rapporto tra le materie prime che riesce
a produrre la terra e le stesse materie
prime che noi riusciamo a consumare e
anche Poi col tempo
a far assorbire come rifiuti Generali
Quindi quando si fa un ciclo completo
completo ma se la l'impronta ecologica
ha anche un un indice di misura che è
questo qua le Heart of shot Days Today e
il giorno in quale è il giorno in cui
noi iniziamo a utilizzare le sostanze e
le le materie prime che sulla terra ci
darebbe l'anno successivo
Quest'anno l'ho vissuto Today è stato il
22 di luglio vuol dire che noi adesso
stiamo già utilizzando le sostanze e le
materie prime della Terra del 2023 ma il
2000 luglio 2022 cioè il luglio di
quest'anno è solo una media
ogni nazione ha un over short Today dopo
vedremo quali sono Nazioni per nazione
una carrellata possiamo far qualcosa per
abbassare fare in modo che guardate nel
1979 Shoot Day era dicembre quindi vuol
dire che noi a dicembre avevamo fatto
tutto il ciclo solare e la Terra era
pronta per ridarci di nuovo i suoi
prodotti Adesso l'ho vissuto io vi ho
detto al 22 quest'anno qua il 21 maggio
è stato il 22 di luglio la cosa
interessante è che ci possiamo
sicuramente fare qualcosa perché se
Guardate il 2020 che è l'anno in cui c'è
stata la pandemia l'ho vissuto Today è
salito di un mese quindi vuol dire che
la condizione di resistenza di viaggiare
bene il lockdown ha portato comunque a
consumare meno risorse e quella potrebbe
essere una strada da indagare per poter
salvaguardare il pianeta e naturalmente
collegata alla nostra salute
Per quanto riguarda l'Italia ad esempio
noi il nostro over Shoot Day è il 15
maggio qui si calcola che dal 15 maggio
in poi noi utilizziamo le risorse del
2023 e noi consumiamo 5 Italia e mezzo
per la nostra quotidianità 5 Italia e
mezzo è tanta roba ma questa media vi
abbiamo detto del 22 luglio è data dal
Qatar che le finisce e le sue risorse il
febbraio quindi già Diciamo in pieno
debito e la Giamaica che lo fa a
dicembre Quindi grazie a queste due
estremi abbiamo una media di questo tipo
per quanto riguarda la salute abbiamo
detto l'ambiente e la salute basta
prendere in esame quelle che sono le
cause di morte le cause di morte del
1900 di morte del 2010 nelle case di
morte del 1900 vedi se sono praticamente
tutte patologie di tipo infettivo gli
antibiotici non erano sarà quelli che
noi conosciamo e quelli che noi
conosciamo in realtà sono per noi una
condanna perché adesso si parla di
antibiotico Resistenza e nei prossimi
anni non avremo antibiotici per curare
le comune polmoniti perché c'è stato un
abuso ok E invece le patologie di tipo
cardiocircolatorio erano al quarto posto
nel 2010 le patologie del cuore e
cancerogene sono salite al primo posto
questi qui sono gli stili di vita questi
qui gli stili di vita errati sul quale
si possiamo fare della prevenzione con
quello che ci siamo detti prima
l'attività fisica la corretta
alimentazione un ambiente sano anche dal
punto di vista emotivo che non ci
stressa quindi qui possiamo intervenire
invece guardiamo le cause di morte in
Italia nel 2020 vedete sempre al primo
posto Abbiamo le malattie del sistema
circolatorio comprende tutto vero
infatti il diabete obesità sindrome
metaboliche secondi sempre i tumori
Allora qui possiamo dire che è la
sedentarietà allo stile di vita qua
possiamo dire Un'alimentazione ricca Da
additivi una una alimentazione anche
diciamo Plus oltre quella che ci serve e
poi vedete malattie del sistema
respiratorio
ricordate E come l'impronta ecologica
l'inquinamento
e la cosa interessante da un certo punto
di vista e che sono salite tantissimi
disturbi psichici che comportamentali io
visito tantissime persone quasi 6000
persone l'anno e vi assicuro che questo
qui sarà un'emergenza per il futuro ne
vedo tantissimi non so se è stato il
lockdown o se è stato la vita che
facciamo che ci porta sempre a
ad esserci un disguido tra la vita
percepita e quella che vorremmo Comunque
le malattie di tipo
psichico sono veramente in aumento
Quindi cosa possiamo fare noi per
cercare di tamponare questa situazione
abbiamo delle carte che possiamo
giocarci
Sì abbiamo delle carte e dobbiamo
risolvere questo misvetch evolutivo cioè
da un lato una tecnologia che va
velocissimo dall'altro un uomo che fa
fatica ad a stargli dietro e quindi di
dare tempo ai nostri processi adattativi
di stare dietro la tecnologia questo
porta tantissimo stress ma abbiamo anche
delle armi a nostro
sul nostro Arco un'arma potentissima per
fermare questa accelerazione abbiamo un
freno a mano che ritornare mettere al
centro la nostra umanità e non si
sentimenti il nostro la nostra
creatività vivere le emozioni come come
siamo capaci nella nostra felicità
interiore che è fatta di cose che non si
percepiscono
voglio concludere ricordando un film del
1999 Qua sono tutti i giovani nessuno
l'avrà visto e L'uomo bicentenario
nell'uomo bicentenario era la storia di
un'azienda che aveva creato un robot che
era un Tuttofare E quindi lui poteva
fare da babysitter e aggiustare la
macchina e curare il prato per qualche
errore non si sa qui l'hardware di
questo robot aveva iniziato a sentire i
sentimenti quindi morirono i suoi
padroni morirono tutti quelli che lui
conosceva e lui si è trovato da solo
perché era immortale era un robot la
tecnologia dell'azienda produttrice era
andata avanti e poteva sostituire il suo
hardware e quindi sentire anche lui le
emozioni però perdeva e perdeva
praticamente
l'immortalità Allora vi dico che mentre
noi cerchiamo di essere multitasking
cerchiamo di acquisire più skill
possibili cerchiamo Siamo davanti al
televisore e rispondiamo a delle mail
magari programma
la lavastoviglie Io penso che se un
robot potesse scegliere vorrebbe essere
un uomo Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]